we're back and I know what you see you
see the folks see the man see enough so
believing me
see the Sun but is he
[Music]
like which names engraved with a saber
language it's a famous big shadows
everybody here with a JB okay to a
secret spy we're gonna Vayner sports
meeting 342 my social for a restaurant
close by an elevator sports hot time the
season building at our draft class
getting very excited about it Brando
headed to this meeting super excited had
a great holiday hope you guys want well
where my Eric Decker t-shirt he's on the
Titans now but what he did yesterday in
the playoff game everybody was [ __ ]
on him he was down he had a big drop and
then he came back with the perseverance
had the big touch that game big shout
out to meet with us I don't like anybody
but the Jets but former Jets still hold
hardness in my heart anyway big meeting
excited to be here in LA for CES this
week back on the grind great family time
to be spending time with AJ quickie
spending time with a lot of you brands
making these biz dev deals with fader
sports this will be a fun episode had a
great break had a lot of time to think
about 2018 feel very focused nothing too
crazy just good solid grinding and focus
on the Vayner ex world and obviously
k-swiss my book those kind of things but
it's just gonna be a it's gonna be a put
it your head down bring your lunch go to
work Ryan dat 15 hours a day kind of
thing and just focus as [ __ ] like really
[ __ ] focused better
good it was actually good yeah bro
it's just a lot to handle cuz it's so
exciting it's just so real yep and it's
such good like think about what I talked
about positivity and mogul life like
it's so good yeah and and legitimate
it's not like some fraud straight around
actually let me give you the meat of
this episode because I know a lot of its
not gonna be able to be seen I've come
to realize it's happening right now with
Vayner sports I just say it's super fun
to do a second go-around with my
favorite man a JV over here there's just
nothing like the beginning of building a
[ __ ] monster there's nothing like it
I love the underestimated
I love the why every single thing I've
done people tell you know actually the
second and third big thing I did
why vaynermedia and why Vader sports
there's an article in banner sports
there's an article on vaynermedia if you
dig on the web enough that says he
doesn't know what he's getting into
this is different let me just promise
all you [ __ ] faces forever none of it's
gonna be different whatever [ __ ]
industry I choose they're in trouble if
we decide to actually do it there's
gonna be a lot that I flirt with and I'm
gonna talk a little bit game but I'll
never go deep but if we go deep
it's a [ __ ] wrap curtains on the
industry and I just uh this is the most
fun like I love the hard part
I love the ex work I love getting on the
phone with a bunch of you that are
filling out the Google form for biz dev
and negotiating a and you want to give
fifteen thousand I want to get it to
twenty five and like you know like so
Commission on that's fifteen hundred
dollars and it's so not worth by fifteen
minutes but it's like trading a baseball
card or it's the game the journey the
ride doing what somebody you respect and
love always makes it so much better but
to be very frank no like I'm sure it's
the same for you even without that part
I I think I like the the part of the
unknown knowing it's gonna happen but
you never know until you know the
descending voices nope motivate me I got
you know I don't know if it's a flaw up
I don't know if it's strength but I
definitely love it and then the moments
yeah like all of you on Twitter going
crazy when you see me in the green room
at the NFL Draft you know like that's
just funny like Gary Vee and then I go
on like live like I don't know the love
you there's like it
and following your like I'm crazy like
that like that [ __ ] anyway if you don't
have the high that I have right now see
this is a key moment this is why that's
what fun and I give you some context but
here's the real punchline if you don't
love it for the loving it and it's about
the money
you've lost like you know like like none
of this is smart for me financially it's
just not but uh it's just the game in
and you know what house providing value
like what was really interesting with
Wine Library in vaynermedia now Vayner
sports is I know that I'm making the
customer happier it's like that Amazon
effect right like you know you Jeff I'm
sure knew he was gonna build a monster
but he also knew he was making it better
for the customer like I changed the
premium price points of wine in America
like they all came down like we put
pressure on people doing better digital
marketing if they don't want to lose
their business and now in sports we're
gonna force agencies to do a lot more
for their athletes because when they can
point to Vayner sports they'd be like
what are the everybody everybody's
everybody's trading on the past they
don't want to let go either why you're
winning they're gonna have to love this
part best part is I'm documenting this
time wish I had this the last two times
imagine our ghetto-ass piece-of-shit
first office and Buddy media's
conference room or sunshine Suites and
we're just like we're gonna do it you
guys don't know our bathroom at
vaynermedia is better than our first
office so in wrapping it up you got to
love it and most of you don't you're
trying to figure out the money you're
chasing the most current thing do you
cryptocurrency or do you think it's a
gold miner that's great
I mean if you're about but like to
really go all-time not to become rich
do you like love it or do you think like
or like you gotta love it it's so much
better it's such a better way
not that crypto Christmas is gonna win
but like you know like it's so much
better than yeah love it they love baths
they love it you know like I get it I
get it I get it 100% about putting
industries hundred percent just love it
though love it for like love it like you
can't wait to wake up and do it
it's so [ __ ] cliche but because I'm
in a moment right this second and you
guys have seen it on my social over last
7 days when I'm hot like that I'm
talking about Vayner sports more in the
last 7 days on social I did in the first
I'm also a funny guy that way I don't um
you know like yeah you know you have a
kid and you're like that not that into
it the first year and because it's cute
but like like like but then it gets
really good you know like I'm a little
bit like that with the first year of a
company - man [ __ ] almost like a
shark right like oh wait a minute that a
drop of blood in the water
I can see enough now everybody's in
trouble like I first you know every now
there's [ __ ] blood
now there's [ __ ] blood baby I'm feel
bad feel [ __ ] bad bad I can't wait to
recall this [ __ ] clip in four years
it's game time it's game time this is
where band stops filming well you can
film a little bit but
so look already come on yeah so look it
was unbelievable like we we couldn't
share anything with you but back then
actually I'm gonna interview you like
the talk you just heard like what's
running through your mind you know it's
funny even my own brother they're not in
a room with me a lot these days what
what are you taking away from the way we
post gamed off this big meeting pretty
unbelievable just seeing how quickly you
put in place for Vayner sports to be the
most insane thing in the world and if it
doesn't happen tonight I like it even
you guys don't understand you do not
understand it if I lose tonight it's
even better how do you [ __ ] beat
somebody like that how do you beat
somebody like me how do you beat
somebody like me you don't I created a
framework that doesn't let you beat me
if I win I win and if I lose I win
actually you're filming right now right
let's please please hey thank you very
nice to meet you right yes sir
nice to meet you what's your name Herman
I'm just saying what's up man - dude
nice to meet you man like you're
describing I love the hustle man do your
thing good luck
thanks for seeing us up how do you beat
this
Justin for the blog
that pizza dude knows who I am for the
blog yeah this was the first time you
really saw me in an environment like
that what'd he have to say the
vaynernation about what you saw don't
stroke it just like shoot it straight as
if I wasn't your dog which I know was
impossible but still try it it was like
a whirlwind literally like you were in a
vortex we talked about it we it was the
Gary show it was full Gary show and it
was like time-lapse when we left a
meeting people were like [ __ ] that was
like a movie I was just it it was Wow
see but we lose a job now I will now I
really want to lose cuz I want to be
able to recall this moment and just be
like cuz that's the game if you don't
love loot if you do not love losing you
[ __ ] lost by the way loving losing is
hating to lose let me clarify this cuz
everyone's confused by this loving to
lose is hating to lose but respecting
the game you play and understand that's
part of the [ __ ] equation you're
doing things differently and so it's
like you know you know I've met the Fed
and what makes me palpable is I get it
like I understand but I knew what had to
be done
listen what do you think I'm good at why
do you think this is such a good
business for me this is the people
business exactly and you know who's the
all-time people person me period that's
what I will go down as like the I like
people I'm a good guy
I'm I'm a [ __ ] I'm the biggest shark
and the biggest [ __ ] like good guy
period and that's facts
nobody knows you better than me even
better in a weird way than like I'm so
much better of a guy then anybody
couldn't even my biggest fan thinks
right cuz he sees the secrets this is
the way I fire people how I take care of
people what I do
was
like the way I saw you or the way I
treat the rock versus the schmock
[Music]
everybody's got different journey
Kurt Warner's going on a Hall of Fame
guy was bagging [ __ ] groceries
that piece of [ __ ] in New England who I
hate more than life I'm a six [ __ ]
round New England's not specially got
lucky that's love
like don't tell me you knew something
you would have taken them a lot earlier
you know never know Kirt water would
have never had his career if Trent green
didn't get her in a pre-season just will
never have to right they're just too
much there's just too much that was
tremendous just like an early moment
getting four of our guys together for
dinner who happened to be out here
training just enjoyed it been incredible
day Boehner Sports is off and rocking
this is the Vayner sports episode I've
said my piece I wish these videos
existed for vaynermedia
I wish even more they existed for Wine
Library but here's a good part babban
they exist for Vayner sports actually
[Music]
[Music]
like stools are you ready busted